we've been uh trying to get him uh for a
few weeks now because i am just
fascinated by his career path and who he
is
he is the quarterback of the new orleans
saints winning his first three career
starts presumably getting ready for the
philadelphia eagles he is
taysom hill how are you chasing i'm
great
i'm great rich thanks for having me on
where have i found you you driving
around the great city of new orleans
right now
uh i'm headed home actually just had a
little stuff to get done in the facility
and and uh
headed home to finish up a little prep
for uh
for for the eagle okay so uh
are are we assuming you're the starter
are you the starter this week is drew
coming back best we can tell
you don't mind me asking straight
forward yeah yeah
uh look i i don't know um
i know that i know that drew is the most
competitive guy
i've ever been around and i know he's
been dying to get back on the field but
um i i don't know i haven't
talked to him to know what his plan is
yet
i think it's one of those things that in
a situation like this
that you know for me i have to make sure
that i'm
i'm preparing to be the guy in case i am
the guy and uh
if if drew's ready to come back you know
it's obviously
it's it's his show um and i'll
and i'll uh step back into my other role
but if not i'll be ready
so uh when we had drew on the show about
three weeks ago he was in the uh
in the i guess the workout room and he
said taysom's right over here
so you've obviously been around him for
quite some time
uh what has it been like for you to be
around drew brees what have you picked
up from him
taste him oh man well that that is such
a loaded question
um that that i could go on forever i i
have learned so much from drew one
he he is such an incredible mentor he's
become such a great friend to me
um but i would say the things that i i
learned most
are not the things that drew has said to
me it's what i've been able to observe
and it's really i think what separates
him from
other people um is how he prepares
for a football game i was so
blown away when i first got here to see
the way that he prepares
week in and week out because i had this
expectation that you know drew's been
playing for so long he's been so great
and so consistent that
you know there's not a defense he hasn't
seen and but i'm telling you he prepares
as if
it's his first start every week
and so his routine his schedule i can
tell you that
you know without me being around him you
know if i was
gone for a week i could tell you exactly
what he would be doing when he would be
doing it because his routine is so
dialed in
and he knows what it takes to get him
prepared for a game and so really his
routine and how he prepares has been the
most beneficial thing
uh for me throughout this process and in
terms of the
the three weeks though that you've been
the starter what about that how has he
been there
downloading you with information or you
picking his brain or anything like that
what about that he's yeah he's been
awesome look i think it's one of those
things where
you know when you're used to taking
every rep and playing every game and
everything it's hard to
you know continue to watch film and
prepare that way but
man he kept that same routine with me he
was then watching film with me
and um you know we we sat and had a ton
of discussions on
you know personnel and game plan and we
were sending different ideas up to the
coaches
um and and so he he's been awesome
you know he's he's been on the sideline
with me for
both atlanta games and um
he's been so helpful through that entire
process taysom hill here on the rich
eisen show let's talk about the journey
i love
journeys i love stories and yours is
fascinating to me
um from idaho and jim harbaugh
knocked on your door for stanford is
that is that the way this kind of
started
for you taste yeah yeah yeah look when i
was coming out of high school i i really
narrowed it down to two schools
um and it was it was stanford and byu
and ultimately i ended up you know
signing play for stanford i really
wanted to play
uh for jim i i felt like uh
he he had a great idea of how he was
going to use me and
and what my skill set was and um you
know he obviously went to the niners
while i was in the mission field and
a few things changed and so i ended up
going to byu and
and uh i love my time there but but yeah
i really enjoyed my time getting to know
coach harbaugh
and uh was was obviously excited about
playing for him
initially so where'd you go on your
mission what was that
yeah i was in sydney australia uh so
graduated on nine and then i was in
australia from 2010
to uh through 2011.
and then you you came and you went to
byu are you aware
um because we had sean payton on the
other day
and i asked him when he first laid eyes
on you taysom are you aware
that that preseason game in 2017 with
the packers where you were
performing um that you were part of a
cut-up tape for max mccaffery that he
was
keeping an eye on he saw you were you
aware that your preseason performance
in a way led to all of this taysom
uh yeah yeah i was you know i i had a
conversation with
with coach when he first claimed he he
told me the story i was actually
with max max was on the on the phone
with coach because coach was trying to
get him to come down with the practice
squad
uh spot and um you know he shared the
story with me as
he was watching max and then he realized
and started asking who's this guy that
that keeps throwing him the ball
and and uh as you alluded to the rest
has been history yeah and he also
said um to a bunch of people i mean when
you were named the starter and it was
quite kind of surprising to a lot of
people that you were the one he turned
to
um that uh that he had told all
manners of broadcasters from troy aikman
to michelle tafoya to anybody when
the conversations were brought up with
them about what if drew went down
certainly with bridgewater now on a
different team after going five-and-oh
in this spot last year
uh he said it would be taysom if we'd
lose brees for any specific period of
time and he wanted to be
true to his word when did he tell you
that
though jason um yeah coach and i had
had a few conversations through training
camp and as we as we final
uh finalized training camp you know we
we had a conversation and
you know the the plan was always
because my role was so unique that you
know something happened to drew mid-game
that
that jameis would finish the game just
because we didn't want to lose two
people
uh because of what i'd be doing that
game
and then you know the next week that
that i would i would have an opportunity
to go
so that was that was our conversation
that was
you know my expectation going into the
season um
and so i wasn't surprised when it played
out that way
but what does it mean to have a coach
actually keep his word
um yeah look i trust i trust coach
payton
um and it it means a lot you know
um obviously sometimes you can have
conversations and then people go back on
the word but i would say that my
experience with coach has
has always been really positive where he
he's certainly a man of his word um but
he is a guy that
like if if he believes in you like he
creates opportunities for you so
um and that's that's really all he's
he's done for me since
i've been in new orleans has created
opportunities for me
and uh that's that's really all you can
ask for as a player
what about opportunities you're creating
for yourself taysom a conversation that
you could be this guy once drew brees
moves on to broadcasting
has that been broached with you at all
uh are you talking specifically with
coach or just
my my thought process with coach how
about that
yeah look i i mean i will tell you that
um
i've always believed in my talents you
know and and
my college career didn't go the way that
i had hoped for and
it was injury written and everything
else um but i've always
trusted in my capabilities of
playing quarterback at this level um and
i will and i will tell you that
i believe coach feels the same way about
me
um now it's it's obviously i've gotta
take advantage of opportunities and play
well to um
to continue to have opportunities but i
i feel super capable
um and and as i look into the future
you know that that is certainly the
long-term goal
to be the guy so now that you have
thrown your first career touchdown
passes
taysom hill what is a better feeling
conver uh completing a touchdown pass
with your arm or running somebody over
to score one which one
look uh yeah i would say i'm still a
quarterback at heart
i love i love throwing i love throwing
touchdown passes
and and more than anything it's it's
because you get other people involved
um i love celebrating with my teammates
i loved going down to
celebrate with trey kwan and and jared
as they
as they caught touchdowns well i mean
you do
involve somebody you truck the person
and then you could still celebrate with
your teammates after trucking the person
taste them you know i've i i have thrown
the ball in my backyard to my children
uh and i do believe i've completed
touchdown passes there
i've never trucked anybody i'm just
wondering which one you like better what
gives you a better feeling when it's all
said and done well
i i like i like throwing touchdowns okay
i like throwing touchdowns and i'll tell
you that
um you feel a lot better the next
morning throwing touchdowns when you do
trucking someone running touchdowns okay
very good so uh when it is all said and
done
this is the role you want for the rest
of your playing career in the nfl what
we are seeing
right now um how how much better do you
think you can get
than what we're seeing right now taysom
hill um
man i i i feel like i can i can improve
in a lot of areas
um you know like what uh hit me up
on some of them yeah well look i i think
the blatant things i
i've got to be better at taking care of
the ball you know i've left the ball on
the ground a couple times right
we had to turn over in the red zone
which which would have certainly
led the points and um that that was
disappointing
aside from that i think the more and
more comfortable i get and i've
i've progressed the last few weeks i
feel like my timing
with the receivers have been better i
think um you know the decision making of
where you're going with the ball and
when when you throw the ball
has continued to get better but i would
i would say that
the progression of a quarterback and
what makes a quarterback good to great
and great to elite is
their ability to process so much
information and then make a decision
based on the information that the
processing so
how quickly can you see it how quickly
can you get the ball where it needs to
go
and i would say that that uh really will
always be
you know my emphasis of playing
quarterback and i think that's really
what
separates the good ones from the great
ones and it's it's been a great learning
experience
from drew because that's what he's he's
done throughout his entire career
um and and what really makes him great
in my opinion
well what about your adjustment takes
them from also going
in the huddle looking at a goat like
drew brees
for the play and knowing you better be
where it needs to be
so you can make sure that your goat uh
who's counting on you gets what he's
expecting
and knowing that of the other teammates
who are potentially going to be on the
receiving end of a of a drew brees pass
to now
having michael thomas be the one looking
at you
in that same way that's got to have been
for the last three games a little bit
jarring
i'm wondering for you
yeah look um right i i
felt i have felt so much support from my
teammates that you know certainly
stepping into a role like this and
trying to
um do your best to
continue to facilitate and play at a
high level like like drew is is
certainly a stressful um and a pressure
environment but um i have felt so much
support from my teammates
you know as i get in the huddle i feel
like they trust me
i trust those guys i know that they're
going to be where they're supposed to be
um
and i i've appreciated that i haven't
felt any additional pressure from
you know mike thomas or emmanuel or
treycoin or jared that
like hey they have some crazy
expectation for me and i think we're all
on the same
page that the goal is to win football
games um
and we we've been able to do that so
you're saying in your first three starts
you haven't had a single instance of
somebody's looking at you saying hey i'm
open
that hasn't happened yet to you as a
quarterback
demanding the football there has been no
demanding of the football in your three
starts
yeah um
hold on it sounds like it sounds like
there has been
it sounds like there has been i would
say guys
guys will come to me and say i've i've
got you you know
okay i'm i'm gonna fight for you
um but
there are moments there are moments like
that but uh
look i i i haven't felt you know there
definitely hasn't been
any confrontation or um
no you know any issues no no no no i
work hey taste them i work for
uh pro with the pro football hall of
famer michael irvin who's
uh uh still to this day adores uh
troy aikman they're tight but troy will
tell you the number of times michael
told him hey
you know what gives um that you know
yeah
these things happen is what i'm saying
that's why i'm wondering if it's
happened to you and
you're now on the business end of it and
how that's been interesting for you
well i'll tell you a big part of it i i
will go to the receivers and say hey
you know were you open were you open on
this play
in the event that we come back to it
because i may have
i may have looked to a different side
and um
you know the pictures didn't show
exactly if they won or how they played
the back side of a route concept
so um guys will tell me but
i i haven't ever felt any you know real
anger or
um you know or malice from
from any of my guys man just just
nothing but nothing but support
and uh if there are conversations like
that it's more of an informational
um deal not a hey i'm i'm upset
they'll give me the ball okay and then
before i let you go in the last couple
of minutes i have here
your support system at home who are they
let's give them a shout out
who who who do you have at home yeah i
i i have the best support support system
um
you know i've been married for uh six
and a half years now
uh we just had our first child uh who
was
almost four months old now so my wife is
is basically living the life of a of a
single mother right now
right boy or a girl boy or a girl uh
little boy
little little boy okay his name's bo
um and then you know my
my parents my wife's parents and and uh
siblings have
have all been outstanding and supporting
us and when they found out that i was
gonna start my first game they all
jumped on a plane and flew down here to
they were here for it and it's been
great fabulous is beau
the swiss army knife of of infants takes
him do we know he's taken after his
daddy so far is he doing it all right
now
he's doing it all he's a little hot and
cold man sometimes he'll sleep well
sometimes he won't and
uh walked over the world yeah there you
go
taste them i really appreciate it i've
been admiring you from afar and i i hope
this is not uh it's the first of many
times that we get to chat here on the
show appreciate the time
yeah sounds great thanks for having me
that's taysom hill at t underscore
hill4 on twitter at ts underscore hill
on instagram
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here